Thinking about UV space,
if we have a particular gradient,
that gives us a line.
That's what this red one shows us.
But suppose we have another gradient,
okay, but in the same little window.
Well, that gradient would
give us a different line.
So here is our, this is gradient 1,
this is gradient 2,
all within the same window.
And then, here's gradient 3, and
it gives us a different line.
Clearly, what's going on, is, if I have
a bunch of these different gradients,
they're all going to intersect at,
at the point.
That point is the correct UV.
So, as long as we have different
gradients within the window,
we can get a solution.
We've seen this before, haven't we?
Here is the equation we just showed you,
A transpose A.
And d equals negative A transpose b,
all right?
When can that be solved?
To just solve this, we would want
A transpose A to be invertible, right?
because if it's invertible,
I just multiply both sides by that, and
I come up with a solution for d.
Okay?
Well when are matrices invertible?
Well they're, and from our linear
algebra we know that they need to be
what's called well-conditioned.
If they're not well-conditioned
then the inverse is unstable, and
basically you can look at
the eigenvalues, all right?
And the ratio of the largest
eigenvalue to the smog,
the smallest eigenvalue
shouldn't be too big.
That's from your conditioning.
In fact, if the second eigenvalue
were 0, l1 over l, or lambda 1 over
lambda 2 would be infinity, and
that'd be awful, all right?
So what we want are eigenvalues
that are, you know,
approximately the same magnitude,
okay, so that will make it solvable.
But wait, we also know when this
should be solvable from the geometric
demonstration we just did.
This whole problem should be solvable,
as long as there are different
gradients within the window.
because if they're different
gradients within the window,
then we get those inner sections
of those lines in uv space.
So does this remind you of something,
gradients and eigenvalues?
Of course it does, because you are like,
right on the ball, all right?
You remember our Harris corner detector?
This matrix, A transpose A,
that is the second moment
matrix of the Harris detector.
And if you remember, we looked at
the eigenvectors and eigenvalues of that
matrix to know whether or
not something was a good corner.